kubernetes networking is famously
designed around core principles that can
vary in implementation
thus it's essential to understand the
specific way cluster networking works
when using gke
[Music]
there are various resources we interact
with in gke so let's break this down
starting with gke nodes in gcp these
nodes are vms that live within the
construct of a vpc
in other words a private network in the
cloud each gke node gets a private ip
and connectivity to the rest of the
cluster and the rest of the network
at cluster creation time you will need
to define your first ip range the node
range from which these nodes will get
their ip address by default creating a
gke cluster will also allocate a public
ip to each node as well
if you want to lock down your cluster
from the internet it's recommended that
you configure gke to run as a private
cluster in which the nodes will not
receive a public ip address if you want
to run a private cluster but also want
to establish outbound connections with
the internet you'll need to configure a
service like cloudnat for egress to the
internet the next resource we want to
review in gke are pods the atomic
kubernetes resource that encompass our
containerized application
in kubernetes each pod gets its own ip
address in gke this is accomplished via
alias ip ranges
this means that each pod will have an ip
address unique in the vpc and can be
natively addressed from other clients in
the network
when you create a gke cluster you will
need to define your second ip range the
range from which pods will get their ip
address
[Music]
each gke node gets a number of ips from
this range that it can assign to its
pods
by default a slash 24 is carved out for
each node which is 256 ips in total pods
can be scheduled and rescheduled on
various nodes throughout the lifecycle
of the cluster
one challenge with this is that it means
that the ip address that each pod gets
may change a number of times
this brings us to our final resource for
which we must configure an ip range at
cluster creation kubernetes services
kubernetes services are how clients
within a cluster can access a target set
of pods via a stable virtual ip
known as cluster ip in kubernetes
at cluster creation time we must define
a private range for those service
cluster ips
client pods can access other pods in the
cluster via a cluster ip associated with
their service
this ip address will remain stable even
as the target pods scale up and down or
shuffle across the cluster
hopefully you've gotten a good picture
of what needs to be configured at
cluster creation time
given that this ip address management
can require careful planning gke has
introduced two features to make this
process easier the first feature is
flexible pod sider
earlier we talked about how each node by
default will get a slash 24 from which
they can assign ip addresses to their
pods
but what if we only plan on running 30
pods on a node
we could potentially strand many ip
addresses
flexible pod sider allows users to
reduce the number of ips that nodes in a
node pool are given to assign to their
pods
for example in node pool a
each node is configured to have a range
smaller than a slash 24 from which they
can allocate ip addresses to their pods
this helps users reduce stranded ip
addresses which is huge when trying to
plan out cluster networking
but what do we do when we cannot predict
how many pods we may actually need to
run in our cluster
this is where the second gke feature
comes into play discontiguous multi-pod
sider
rather than trying to get a single pod
range size correct at cluster creation
time
this feature allows users to
incrementally increase the ip range
provided for pods
for example in this diagram we have a
second pod range in blue that we have
added after cluster creation for pods
in summary we need to ensure we plan out
and allocate ip space for nodes pods and
services when we create a gke cluster
gke provides additional features to help
with this planning enabling users to
preserve ip addresses and incrementally
grow their clusters network over time
now that we've covered the essentials
for setting up cluster networking in gke
visit the links here to learn more with
the concepts discussed in this video
we're confident you'll be on your way to
building a gk cluster that suits your
needs stay tuned as we expand on other
gk topics in gke essentials
[Music]
you